[Musique]
courbet première partie nord en gros
cyril a fait appel à moi
première chose que j'aime driver les
chroniqueurs je fais des vidéos
humoristiques depuis maintenant un
paquet d'années sur le web qui sont
venus référente sur la toile on va dire
maintenant je passe en coaching
voilà vous puissiez vous vous appuyez
sur moi et mon succès six motifs c'est
l'adrénaline que ça me procurer le
plaisir de consolider des carrières
fragile main dans la main avec puisque
le méné vraiment fragile mais ça fait 30
ans que je fais ça et je m'aperçois tu
vois que j'ai une certaine fragilité
c'est des gens comme toi qui vont
m'aider à construire une vraie carrière
après 30 ans aujourd'hui a rien qui me
fait plus plaisir en fait de faire
connaître un succès sucrés dans sa
cuisine ou rejeter fous rires mais ça va
je pensais à autre chose j'ai beaucoup
tourné cet après midi mais non j'essaie
de faire connaître un succès comme moi
je peux connaître depuis un an va dire
quoi deux ans même sans fin l'apogée
désolé c'est la pratique jerry petit
bout de te dire j'ai j'ai nommé lui en
tournée je sais que je me dise pourquoi
tu es là parce que moi je dire on l'a
pas grand bruit
vous êtes plusieurs en fait avoir besoin
de mon aide aujourd'hui qu'il ya
différents types d' aide à apporter
toi tu es vraiment le point
d'interrogation de la bande des pmp pour
moi tu autant de gaza j'ai très vite
cerné le mec il a du talent mais parce
qu'il n'est pas très futé il s'est vite
cassé la gueule gré
c'est ridicule c'est exclu que des
réunions de ma vie mais toi
contrairement à cast a pas réussi à
aller au mais finalement sans beaucoup
de talent car oui je me suis bien
débrouillé c 'est pas été facile et bon
je vais vous voyez un peu ce que j'avais
pas talent il fallait à chaque fois que
je contourne et ça me fait super plaisir
ce que tu dis on sait pas si on t'aime
pas te voit pas grand chose tu vas tu es
un peu de transport c'est la
transparence qui fait qu'on avait vu que
je suis pour le fait parce qu'on m'a dit
on cherche mais qui colle bien aux
fenêtres et vous est transparent vous
êtes vraiment son invention
donc en fait toi tu tes cachets toujours
derrière des énormes marque tpm paix
sans aucun doute est en fait du coup les
gens ont pas pu s'apercevoir de ce côté
sans plus que tu as toi sans plus ce qui
a fait que finalement tu as toujours été
un planqué mais planqué malin donc ça
c'est un complément je te fais tout ça
se veut vraiment plaisir que pourquoi et
on choisit de soif y allons pour faire
ce cadeau parce qu'ils auraient pu
mettre car nous de la rue enfin
n'importe quel type avec des lunettes
parce que finalement c'est plutôt ça qui
fait un peu de ta vie avec eux une
sangsue pour moi ta force et les
lunettes mais je le dis vraiment sincère
brieuc caisse il y avait deux mecs
étaient des bombes atomiques qui n'ont
pas été pris qui l'ont fait appeler la
deuxième partie du casting fait entrer
ceux qui ont des lunettes là je suis
arrivé dans ce sentier des greens du web
server fait sur ce que j'ai expliqué que
je suis avec une sauce au québec parce
que j'avais des lunettes donc je prends
cette tresse de sérieux c'est ça que je
veux dire donc tout en sort aujourd'hui
le cul bordé noé aujourd'hui tu as
encore chroniqueurs
c'est à dire que ça associé à ta gueule
d'experts comptables oh [ __ ] c'est bon
tous les chroniqueurs de l'émission je à
tous les voir je vois tout de voir un
parent il y en a que je veux bien voir
ils sont sauvable et y en a ils sont si
je ne dis pas qu'il est plus heureux que
je t'assure je veux pas ça mais tu est
ce la fin tu es salaam enfin ça c'est
une supernova nature photocure direct
dans quelques instants que jerry aller
en me disant [ __ ] t'es qu'un essai de
comptable jeux vieux qui finistère
pourrit tout est arrivé à leur tête
comme ça c'était compliqué mais là si tu
me lis je suis sereine je vais avoir
cette petite lueur tout le temps qui va
m'accompagner il faut qu'on ne se
salissent peut-être reprendre
aujourd'hui tu es là mais les gens ils
veulent ils n'ont pas forcément envie de
te voir et c'est le problème et même
pour toi ce sera un jeu grâce le forez
en plusieurs fous autrement on devait ce
que tu comptes faire
donc après avoir retiré tpm paix on
développe un programme web avec toi à
forte valeur ajoutée autour de ta
personne à programme web une mini-série
tout à fait monsieur et découvrez demain
la deuxième partie de l'épisode avec
l'idée de programme que j'ai proposé à
julien pour le rendre plus rock'n'roll
real mais je dirais ça tu entends jamais
jeudi
[Applaudissements]